I want to play this little clip for you
guys some of you have probably seen it
yeah I think so yeah all right so it's
not long it's only two minutes but just
to give you an idea of what cops have to
put up with let's just play this real
quick so the audio is not so hot so I
mean you guys are cops
what's all happening here it looks like
a roadside pull over and he's having him
walk a line is this is this because he's
drunk or DUI like what does this look
like yeah okay so they're just making
sure this guy's you know on the straight
and narrow you obviously can't walk a
straight line so they're gonna cuff them
so nice getting tased right is that
excessive force
I'm gonna say no I'm gonna say no I mean
you saw the gun fall off or the guy this
yeah and you know they tase him and he's
still fighting them right things are
still on he probably hit him like three
times it please yeah
same time there's no amount of forces
yeah fortunately the opt-ins are gonna
make it look like excessive force though
right
so now he breaks free and then he goes
and gets a gun out of his car a second
gun and now he's unloading the clip
through the back window that was the
chance to drive off it's like alright
see ya I'm out
it looks like the trailer tried to cut
him off but done like that's I mean how
often does that happen
honking yeah a lot more often than you
think it doesn't always shoot out or
something but I mean you know we you
gotta you gotta wrestle and get down
like almost on a daily or at least a
weekly basis with some of these days
like yeah I watched that video and I
think to myself you could not pay me
enough money to do what these guys are
doing to deal with that happy horseshit
like you leave your house your family
perhaps I mean you put on a vest you
obviously have training and but even in
that instance I mean if if the media
wanted it to twist that around or slice
it and dice it they could turn around
like well you know they they beat it you
know they beat up this black man and you
know poor him but they're taking bullets
from this guy right and he's clear like
there's something wrong with him I don't
I don't see
the point in being a police officer in
today's day and age not just dealing
with that kind of stuff but the way that
the general mainstream media portrays
policing and your approach to the
general public I had some questions here
what does the mainstream media get wrong
in general in your opinion like you know
we can just go around so we'll start
with Mike I am my opinion they want the
story and they want the story as fast as
possible and so they will let
speculation and rumor run wild they're
not too interested in the facts and
often legal requirements and police
services don't allow us to put up those
facts as fast as we want it or as fast
we want to get it out and then the rumor
becomes the truth and they're almost
sort of glorifying that sort of
mainstream narrative right now of racist
cops of police brutality so that's where
I think they are right now Jesse so the
question again is what is the media get
wrong about policing or you guys you
know specifically I think they try to
sell a much a much more savage picture
than when you take that scenario there's
there's nothing there's nothing pretty
about that and when it comes down to you
know you die on the side of the road
versus going home you kind of got to do
what you got to do I mean the haymakers
for example well if somebody drove by
and seen that and go holy [__] they're
beat the [__] out of that dude but they
don't you know they don't know that he
just put three rounds in there good yeah
obviously I mean there was probably some
people driving by with your self holds
up you know capturing the beating that
the guy took on the ground with the
Taser but you know they miss parts of it
so parts of the story are definitely
missing on the beat so what do you find
typically the media or the mainstream
media gets wrong about policing I think
they get almost all of it wrong to be
quite honest is there anything they get
right then or is it like oh there's an
immediate Ori with my department this is
not going to be good yeah actually
we're going through that right now there
is a media story with where I work and
before even any other fact before we can
even investigate it the media is already
painting the whole picture they're
basically telling us things we didn't
know about our own investigation and
that's somehow they figure it out and
today is it manufactured or is it
truthful like actual manufactured mostly
interesting a lot of it is it's a it's a
I'm not going to discuss it too much but
it's an interesting situation and they
kind of ran with it
you know it's kind of manufacturer make
up their own stuff to fit their their
narrative and go along with what's
happening today and you know but I think
it's I think the people with a lot of
laces know the least about police work
you know I mean we all want to train all
the cotton like I'd say almost every cop
out there is out there to be good but
you know you're gonna have bad people
you go you can go to McDonald's and have
the guy that's gonna spit in your food
or whatever that just doesn't get as
much publicity as you know please work
these days but you know I feel like a
lot of people don't really know what
what goes on in their communities you
know a lot of people go home enjoy their
family hangout enjoy their evening wake
up go back to work and they don't know
what's going on next door or two doors
down or on the block over you know
they're completely oblivious to what
happens and you know so when this stuff
happens people act like cops just go out
there and look for this confrontation
you know that's that's just not the case